here with reaction florida senator marco
rubio senator this is harassment this is
intimidation and the law couldn't be any
more clear i read the statute uh what
part of that law is merrick garland
missing here
he's missing the whole thing first of
all it is illegal look if i can't call a
supreme court justice tonight and say
hey i know you have a case before you i
really like you to rule that way you
can't do that if i can't call them on
the phone and say that how can you
assemble a mob with pitchforks and
torches and go outside their private
home and people say peacefully assembled
that's not true the message behind
showing up at someone's house is we know
where you live we're going to make you
uncomfortable we're going to make your
family uncomfortable and by the way
there's 100 of us here 99 of us are
going to go home and you never know if
one whack job either here or somewhere
else is going to show up in the middle
of the night and try to harm you that's
the message behind showing up at
people's home it is an open effort to
intimidate supreme court justices on
their decision it's illegal it's
improper it should be condemned and it's
going to lead to bad places this is
going to become a two-way street
unfortunately because you'll see this
happen the other way at some point we
shouldn't be doing this they should put
a stop to it right now senator imagine
if i gave out the address of a
congressman or a senator or justice a
liberal justice somewhere
i would never do it it's too dangerous
you know maybe you can explain the logic
behind this i mentioned the 574 riots in
the summer of 2020. i mentioned january
sixth i mentioned what's happening now
in front of the homes of supreme court
justices my question to you is why is it
of all of those incidents democrats only
are outspoken about one
when we're outspoken anytime any
violence any place anywhere
is going on it's the same pattern so for
the left right violence intimidation all
these things are appropriate as long as
the people doing it hold the position
that they agree with we saw that in the
summer of 2020 when they were saying
look you know
you know riots are the language of
people that feel like they have no power
and they can't speak out and it's the
same here they're saying well you know
these are people that are outraged and
they're cheered on you know why these
groups do it because they know people
like those whoever those ladies were
there talking you know people like that
are going to be out there cheering them
on and they know political leaders in
the senate we have senate leaders that
are saying i don't see a problem with
people showing up outside their homes
they know they're going to be cheered on
and and it's across the board this is a
radical left-wing party radical
left-wing party who believes and
supports an abortion paid for by
taxpayers on demand up to the date of
birth that's their position that's the
vote they want here tomorrow that's why
they're running somebody against me in
florida they want to take me out and
replace me with someone named val
demings a do-nothing pelosi puppet
congresswoman who supports
taxpayer-funded abortion on demand up to
the moment of birth by the way i've
asked everybody out there if you don't
want florida to go crazy or in a crazy
direction you know go on my website
learn more about this crazy
congresswoman marco rubio.com and help
me because otherwise we got to beat
these people at the ballot box in
november but this needs to be stopped
these protests right now and leaders who
refuse to condemn it should be called
out for it senator your re-election is
pivotal if the republicans are to have
any chance of taking back the senate and
you've done a great job for the people
of florida um and and i hope people go
to your website i hope they learn a lot
about your campaign you know as we look
at all of this happening and we see
everything going on with the economy is
there a single thing that you can point
to that you can say is a success for joe
biden and the democratic party and what
has happened to this party because it's
unrecognizable to me democrats used to
hide their radicalism now they're more
outspoken you're going to vote on a bill
tomorrow i understand that would allow
abortion what up until the moment of
birth that is that really taking place
tomorrow
you cannot be a democrat nominee for a
major office and support a single
exception
a single restriction you can't you can't
support a single one of them the
position of most democrats today the
press never asks them about it ask them
i hope the press will ask them what
restrictions do you support they will
not answer that because you can't get
the nay roll endorsement unless you are
in favor of taxpayer-funded abortion at
any time during the pregnancy on demand
up to the moment of birth that's the
only way you can get
their endorsement and every democrat
either doesn't want to talk about it or
admits it or just refuses to answer the
question and they know the media won't
ask them
all right uh senator rubio uh your
election is pivotal we need you back in
the senate thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else